salut tout le monde c'est lucas l'ex de
secret tu le fais je suis anthony de
cuisine
allez c'est parti comme moi sont de
qualité oui cela a l'air très bon oui
très bien rester coi attention attention
tu pourrais te blesser
vous êtes assez fraîches me paraît beau
parfum et toute moyenne voyons voir si
on veut chauffer très bien et comment de
ferrié chauffer maintenant la culture
non ce n'est pas plutôt ses boutons ça
n'a pas l'air si c'est michel away très
bien alors donc une sauce tomate
attentats ont tué trop lent que tu es
trop long mon ami quelles sont donc
c'est un gagnant dans son assiette
c'est le changement de change est petit
mais non là c'est la blessure
autrement dit la sauce éclaboussante
[Musique]
aujourd'hui légale à cela oui tout à
fait très bien je vais maintenant juste
passé voir ces gens si michael tu m'a
prêté son portable tu dis quoi ces
quelques centaines de personnes qui te
regardent euros
merci multi alors temps je vous présente
le plus gros molosse de l'univers alors
monsieur bono statut donc à dire alors
alors nous voulons
ouais super bon allez alors quoi qu'il
en soit on vous dit tout ça bientôt ça
me
je m habille alès samuel l le jour des
cloches alors cette heure mais d'un
squatteur c'est chez cet homme il n'a
pas de courseulles il va squatter chez
cet homme est donc lui bah ouais bon
allez ciao
[Musique]